what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
news that I think is going to excite a
lot of Marvel fans ever since Marvel
essentially got the rights back to use
the Netflix Marvel characters fans have
been wondering and hoping that we would
see some of these characters now pop up
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe rumors
went crazy for a while and then our
hopes and our dreams were answered they
announced Daredevil born again with
Charlie Cox returning as Matt Murdoch
and Daredevil in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe well I guess our wishes were
kind of answered when Matt Murdock
appeared in Spider-Man no way home but
this is the official series 18 episodes
it's big and today's report is just as
big as it's been rumored that the
Punisher could be returning and he could
be making his MCU debut in Daredevil
born again that's right Daredevil and
The Punisher in one series and that's
not all of the good news the rumor also
states that the Punisher could be
getting his own Disney Plus show as well
in fact it looks like several of the
Defenders are going to be showing up in
the MCU and or getting their own show on
Disney plus and the Daredevil show is
going to act as sort of a vehicle for
all of this to actually happen Daredevil
is bringing everybody together again and
then they're gonna go their separate
ways kind of they're going to go off
into their own shows and of course I'm
assuming they are going to still
interact with each other every now and
then so let's break down these reports
and talk about the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because it looks like
it's about to get much better than we
ever thought it would now it's really
hard to trace back the first report or
rumor of this as a lot of people have
been talking about it but recently I
believe it started with Casey Walsh over
at the gww.com yesterday he tweeted
responding to another tweet that said
Alaqua Cox will return as Maya Lopez and
Daredevil born again and he said I know
I was in denial about this but but it
sounds like another popular character
will show up as well due to a scheduling
conflict as it appears they will take
the rumored role Jessica Jones had there
is more to this but first let's talk
about this specific part one Aqua Cox
will return as my Lopez and Daredevil
born again that's pretty
self-explanatory we even know for a fact
that Daredevil is going to be in the
Echo series and that Kingpin is going to
be the villain of both Echo and the
Daredevil series but the next part is
very very interesting it appears that
Jessica Jones was supposed to show up at
some point in time in the Daredevil Born
Again series for a cameo however it
would appear that due to some scheduling
conflicts Kristen Ritter cannot appear
on the show that in itself is a pretty
big bummer right there I really like
Kristen Ritter and I really love Jessica
Jones and I would have loved to see her
show up in Daredevil born again but the
fact that this was even a possibility is
super exciting and gives me hope that
we'll see her down the road but the
other part to this is where it says that
it looks like another popular character
will show up to replace her and this
character is supposedly The Punisher and
of course I am specifically talking
about Jon bernthal's Punisher it
wouldn't make sense to reboot only some
of these characters and keep the actors
the same and get new actors for other
roles that would be super super
confusing so a lot of people have been
saying that this surprise Cameo this
replacement Cameo for Jessica Jones is
going to be the Punisher and this
morning Charles Murphy of Murphy's
multiverse.com even tweeted about it as
well and he said f-w-i-w which I believe
stands for for what it's worth I too
have heard about the burn thought Buzz
may remember months back I said I was
told to pump the brakes on Ritter
joining Echo Daredevil born again and
this is why and bernthal's name was
mentioned I will also say that I am
absolutely not confirming just sharing
what I heard so Charles Murphy was
originally talking about Jessica Ritter
joining Echo Daredevil but was told to
hold off on that and the reason why is
because of of that scheduling conflict
that was mentioned before Jessica Jones
was supposed to appear but apparently
she cannot now but Charles Murphy has
confirmed that he has also heard John
bernthal's name mentioned as somebody to
fill in that Cameo slot so these are two
reliable people in the industry talking
about John Bernthal returning as The
Punisher in Daredevil and hopefully for
more in the MCU in fact it does seem
like Marvel Studios is trying to do more
soft reboots of the Netflix series
characters bringing them into the MCU
and giving them their own shows again
we'll dive into that but first big thank
you to Mint mobile for sponsoring this
video most people know about mint mobile
because of Ryan Reynolds but most people
don't know about mint Mobile's amazing
quality now I live in the mountains and
service isn't too good however mint
mobile sent me a free plan and I get
better service with their plan than I do
with my other provider but what's crazy
is their plan is so much cheaper mint
mobile offers Wireless for just 15 bucks
a month they give you the best rate
whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint mobile families start
at only two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network plus mint Mobile's Modern
Family Plan lets you mix and match data
plans so everyone gets the amount of
data that's right for them and you can
use your own phone and keep your same
number and contacts so to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
including the Modern Family Plan go to
mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
bill down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic so the great news
is that it looks like the Defenders at
least some of them are going to be in
the MCU and it looks like some of them
are going to be getting their own Disney
Plus shows and it looks like Marvel
Studios has already established their
formula of how to introduce these
characters and then give them their own
shows it's pretty much what they're
doing for Daredevil we saw Daredevil or
should I say we saw Matt murder appear
in Spider-Man no way home he is now
about to appear in She-Hulk we believe
the very next episode since we got a
pretty big teaser for him at the end of
the last episode then he's going to be
appearing in the Echo series and then of
course he gets his own series Daredevil
born again they also kind of did the
same for Echo they introduced her first
in the Hawkeye series and now she is
getting her own Series so this kind of
seems to be the formula introduce the
Punisher and or Frank Castle in the MCU
in another show basically teasing him
and letting the audience go wow before
he gets his own show same thing for
Jessica Jones tease her like she was
supposed to be teased apparently in the
Daredevil series and then spin her off
and give her her own series or at least
her own storyline and a bunch of other
series and this is what Kevin feige has
actually been teasing us with when he's
been talking about the street level team
he's mentioned the supernatural team the
cosmic team and the street level team
and he even mentioned at one point in
time Daredevil and Spiderman man teaming
up with each other however it looks like
we're not stopping with Daredevil and
hopefully we are getting a good majority
of the Defenders back perhaps Luke Cage
could show up perhaps Iron Fist could
show up and Rosario Dawson also
mentioned her interest in returning as
Claire Temple as well and recently I
even heard a rumor although I'm not sure
how credible it is but I heard a rumor
that Eldon Henson could be returning as
foggy Nelson in Daredevil as well so
Marvel has their plan and Kevin feige
did mention that pretty soon we would
start to see that plan come together and
I for sure hope that the plan is to have
a defender's team and not just them but
them combining with other members like
Spider-Man She-Hulk our new Captain
America falcon and basically be a street
level Avengers team I think this is a
really great plan by Marvel Studios
because I think the fans are really
going to enjoy seeing these Netflix
characters return played by the original
actors this combined with new characters
being introduced to the MCU right now
through Disney plus and also the movies
this is going to make for one heck of an
MCU and not to mention a really large
MCU especially with the mutants coming
up pretty soon as well I'm certainly
excited for the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and I'm sure you are
as well so let me know all of your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below let me know how excited you are
for John Bernthal to return as The
Punisher hopefully fingers crossed and
Jessica Jones and others as well please
don't forget to give the video a thumbs
up and subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest Marvel news for
live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof